I forgot how to do long division
actually freaking love math feel like I
need another shot I was a math major so
I hope I can do 6th grade math still
very good here we go not seen her
friends decide to buy bulk fudge from
the candy store if they bought 5 pounds
of fudge and each person was five
sevenths of a pound of fudge then how
many people can get to share the fudge
was some kind of Nancy's play that she
needs to buy five pounds of petrified
this equals a hold this right here Plus
this equals a whole my answer is three
point five I really want chocolate right
now 0.3 pounds 7 friends my god a
teacher awards her student with two
jujubes for every test question they get
correctly the test has 88 questions and
Damien got a quarter correct
if Makayla also gave Damien 28 of her
jujubes
how many jujubes did Damien end up with
what are these jujubes I don't know what
that is you know like that for nearly
division I have like the quotient like
the quotation the quotient the quote
[ __ ] it's rain oneness it's 72 I'm going
with 72 my answer was 24
because answer is 70 did
[Applause]
that Chloe vodka vodka for V two trains
leave different cities heading towards
each other at different speeds train a
traveling 17 miles per hour leaves LA
and is heading towards Las Vegas 260
miles away at the same time train B
travels from Vegas to LA at 60 miles per
hour at what time do the trains meet the
worst questions start with two trains
why why is this so hard this is easy but
I can't do it
it's like [ __ ] inception honestly
nobody can see for the foreseeable
future 69 minutes according to my
calculations all I could come up with
was 3:20 I said two hours I said
honestly 45 minutes the correct answer
was two hours two hours from now two
hours I honestly don't think I could
have done these questions sober like at
all really no honestly I think alcohol
may have helped me here that was
eye-opening if I was in sixth grade I
definitely would not take shots of
tequila before our quiz you're the one
that's humming when you do
did anybody tell you that that you home
[Music]